now a couple from West Sussex have been
revealed as the winners winners of the
latest euromillions jackpot proper good
news story this steve thompson and his
wife lenka said that the 105 million
pound win would transform their family's
life they have three children the two
oldest currently share a bedroom it's
the sixth euromillions prize to be won
in the UK this year
I'll check the ticket Friday morning I
was a I was gonna go to work I find me
work partner and he said I'll give us a
half hour so I sat on the sofa check the
ticket before I check the ticket wall
I've got spare minutes pulled the phone
out got numbers up had the ticket in one
hand and the numbers just jumped boom
straightaway
it's that you need to talk to me in
person first of all I saw something up
until children and he called me out a
son is born oh my god I thought both men
went back to work yeah yes life goes on
still had to go paint a ceiling my
oldest reaction
he's a very sensible kid he just said
dad can I have my own room no problem of
course she can son and my middle child
the ten year old he said can I have a
Tesla said not a chance
and what would just ask for a pink
iPhone so I think she's going to get
that too it's so much money I'm gonna be
generous I live in a small village it's
a nice village I don't want to leave the
village so whatever I can do in the
community
I will it will I've got to be sensibly
generous at the end of the day I'm still
Steve I still want to live where I do
this is still known can we don't want to
change we're just going to be
financially better off and so will a lot
of other people